[Music]
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
we're live
do it live now how annoying was it when
we started yeah let's get it what they
need to know about knowing that it was
like a seven out of ten so we started
and he turned
he turns the air off
he turns the air off and then gets the
cameras ready now why is that bad well
because it's very very very very very
hot outside and therefore very hot
inside it's 102 degrees outside it is
that's awful right and he turns the air
off and then gets the cameras ready when
he should get the cameras ready and then
turn the air off right the air should be
going as long as possible
right until up to the moment we're about
to start so we get the fullest extent of
the air for the longest amount of time
correct scientists ought to work now
that's the truth okay number one now
look at me look what i'm
doing i was gonna ask who wanted to go
first but i guess you do
pure spectrum gummies i eat them it
helps with my restless syndrome
he's been complaining about restless leg
syndrome for [ __ ] ever and guess how
annoying it is
10 out of 10. okay but and now it's not
annoying right because i take it
to them whatever it's called what's it
called pure spectrum okay it's pure
spectrum no thc but anyway i'm gonna
provide a link i'm gonna provide a link
for you guys under this and you can get
ten percent off of this uh
by using the code oh congrats my other
podcast i'm so sorry oh congrats no
congrats all right well why are you
[ __ ] hacking other shows [ __ ] i know
my show i know i feel like my [ __ ]
show because i'm up because i'm a brand
ambassador my baby now i put this under
my [ __ ] tongue anxiety levels the
[ __ ] down i'm serious and no [ __ ]
wrestle saying i don't understand it's
like a magic are you gonna know if it
performed well here if you're using the
other code
i'm using the congrats code he's using
the congrats code that's what i'm saying
say like you should say use code
lifeline and tell them to have a code oh
so confusing
what you're saying let's see what you're
saying well right now the code's
congrats if you want it you can't change
it it's the code's congrats
guy says or lifeline it's not lifeline
okay you know and in other news so worst
news already a lot of you guys uh
dm me and you're like
hey because i give i'm the one that
gives good advice chris gives whatever
the [ __ ] i don't i give good advice take
pure spectrum cbd for you russell sager
during the show you give also generally
stupid advice you know okay uh i give
good advice and you seem to all uh
recognize that and appreciate it the
problem is sometimes you write to me via
dm asking me for advice and let me tell
you something i'm not gonna do that
because that takes up too much of my
time time and also this is a [ __ ] job
not a recreational hobby
so now that being said
i have decided
to give private advice sessions
available to you all go to my website
mattalia.com you can book 20 minute or
40 minute sessions it's just me your
[ __ ] boy don't say jesus like that
and uh oh it's cool yeah yeah you should
do it you need advice on a lot of things
you can sign up i'll sign up uh yeah and
that's the deal so do that now matt
dalia dot com
go schedule private advice with me will
you be a [ __ ] boy will you be saying
give sp will you be giving will you be
saying the spin move stuff at all
absolutely never okay well you i will
make sure
i will i can't guarantee it because that
gets into legal issues but i will make
your life more pimp and pimp and i
promise you oh more private payment
definitely okay to be you could say that
yeah well well your honor his life he
did make his life more pimp and pimping
um and also i will say this dude um
completely forgot what i was gonna say
nice yes dude too much of that [ __ ]
thc no he's not that that's
yes dude word recall is terrible wow
dude wow uh if you take apart let me
finish i wasn't gonna make a comment
about the cbd i was gonna make a comment
about thc which is not in there right
have you ever taken thcs nope
have you ever drinking alcohol no
took a step i was there when he took a
sip and guess what you did spit it out i
didn't mean to take a sip once uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
anyway dude uh
i forget what i was gonna say it was
funny as [ __ ] and now you guys don't get
to have it because you know the first
time
i don't actually i haven't even taken
that but in a long time though after ex
of gabapentin
gavin penton gavin penton i was kevin
clinton gabapentin dude the name of the
why don't they make [ __ ] medical
names easy they don't want to they want
to make it so you can't say it because
then you got to pay the guy who knows
how to say it right it adds to like the
separating of
the dumbasses like us and the professor
yeah definitely
you thought that before i mean not like
in a conspiracy way but i do think that
terms in general groups come up with
terms to exclude
not for any other reason they'll be like
i'm going to make up this like fancy
[ __ ] term so that only we understand
it and people outside of this group
won't understand it and they got to come
to us to gain understanding i'm smart
do you think that that's why we came up
with rank
no runk was on this on the [ __ ] fly
on the spot but what i'm saying but
people don't know what it is unless they
come to us and they say hey what's wrong
yeah but you were making a joke you
didn't think oh i'm gonna exclude people
now you just said something funny i love
excluding people okay well that's your
own
problem um i will say though that i was
on the road this weekend okay and how
was that i have a video out there it's
called the tor report and it's on my
crystallia channel but on youtube and it
was awesome yeah it sounded honestly you
you're really transparent on text like i
can always tell when you're in a [ __ ]
mood in a whatever mood uh in like a
ditzy mood which is what you usually are
in and then also when you're in a good
mood yeah and it was very obvious from
before you
went out to
dallas it was dallas right uh-huh and
while you were in dallas your mood was
like crazy crazy elevated yeah i was
down before that
i still have ups and downs you know when
i'm on the road but uh
it was great to get to see my family
because kristen and calvin were in st
louis and then they met me in dallas and
when i saw them it was great dude when
he wears the [ __ ] uh your earphones
it's so cute
but um so i was in dallas and i was in
uh wichita and it was great
and uh opened up with some btk killer
jokes in wichita i bet those killed
i don't like jokes like that but i don't
care
i don't care that you don't like them
other people like them you're not the
only person in the world that's how it's
gonna be by the way when you sign up for
his advice
but uh
i don't care bloom yeah and uh and so
now i have uh atlanta which is sold out
hey would you look at that good for you
and
and then i have washington dc limited
tickets left and then stockton
coming up in california yep been there
wow you have yeah why have you been to
stockton just going through you know i'm
a rambling man i used to be around with
a man oh no i'm kind of more sedentary
but i used to be a rambling man cool
just learned the words and uh
today class and when i was a rambling
man
stockton was a place i ended up
[ __ ] a johnny cash song when i was a
rambling man stockton was a place i
would end up in ended up in two times
not would end up it's not theoretical i
did end up there too i was a rambling
man i used to uh
i would end up in stockton when i was a
rambler man i would end up in auckland
when i was a rambling man
well two times in stockton i wanna
what two times in stockton would be the
name of this song when i was a rambler
man i wound up and talked in two times
when i was a ramon man
so i'll be in stockton and then oakland
uh i've been thinking about getting a
bulletproof vest
no yeah a nice segue i think about
getting a bulletproof vest and just
rocking it dude tupac did it and
honestly he looked [ __ ] fantastic
he got shot to death in public he got
caught sleeping he wasn't wearing it oh
well
if you're gonna here's the thing if
you're gonna get a kevlar vest you gotta
wear it all the time
you don't like have it on sometimes
you don't go halfway with a bulletproof
vest
you got to wear it like when you go to
sleep only take it off when you shower
sharing with the bluffer
i guess under it
[Laughter]
yeah exactly um yeah dude i want to get
a tan one it would look really cool but
you know like for style you want to get
them for style well dude i want to also
look good a full black one that's long
is the [ __ ] um with a chrome hearts
cross over it you know and then uh um
a tan one is also a [ __ ] a high tan one
that leaves your belly exposed so you
wouldn't get shot in the [ __ ] stomach
but a high tan one is good and a long
black one is the [ __ ] that's something
that has always bothered me about
bulletproof anything it's like you gotta
get the full body everything mm-hmm or
else they're just gonna shoot you in the
head or hands just go out in like the
full like yeah with covering up your
feet
picture the guy
get a onesie ah dude steve navarro with
the [ __ ] with the kevlar vest on get
a bulletproof version oh dude
see i wouldn't that's the one i wouldn't
get we got to show this on the on the
thing make sure you keep these for the
show but this is the one the these are
the ones i wouldn't get the the cloth
ones i want a full with the plate in it
but
that one's the [ __ ] dude cloth doesn't
work so why would they be no it does
they have like material that like
bounces and it won't penetrate yep
that's 125.
that's it
that is cheap
that doesn't get up oh get a pink one
those are dope
right right
right right right
so anyway i think i'm going to get one
but i don't know if it'll be here at the
time for stockton but god damn that
would be so ill dude i would be cool
like that there's the pink ones you know
all right dude now we're talking
now i now i would wear a pink one
let's see chris is being colorblind
because he clicked on the only red one
that was of course and there were pink
ones those are pink ones
that's for look they have it for chicks
that's hilarious
um i will wear it though so i'm not a
chick so it's not true um i guess we
could start okay yeah yeah uh let's get
into the advices
what's up mate and chris thanks for what
you guys do lifeline [ __ ] rocks
congratulations [ __ ] rips and not
enough people know about matali is
confused that podcast is awesome too
coming back later this year baby throw
that out there look it up
anyway speaking of confused that's where
i come in
i'm an extremely extremely nostalgic
person to the point where
everything i think about and do
revolves around the past gotta be
careful uh looking forward stresses me
out the future stresses me out
i've never been one to have goals or
want a career um even today stresses me
out
um so i wasn't sure what to do as far as
being super nostalgic to the point where
that's where i am
24 7 just about
um obviously it's comfortable in the
past you know what happens it's easy to
go back to it and the future is scary so
i'm 31 years old
living like that's not productive i need
to get my head screwed on straight any
advice would be great how do i get out
of the past how do i get to the future
thanks guys
well it's a simple question it's it's
it's complicated but it's a simple
question do you want to be a mega
[ __ ] or do you want to not be a
mega [ __ ] because that's the
whole thing that magga is based on what
it's looking back and longing for a time
but it's a trick because we think of the
past and it's like
we think of it as way way rosier than it
really was and like he sort of alluded
to when we think of the future it's
unsettled it's up in the air like you
you know we could all get [ __ ] shot
next day just walking around not if you
have the vehicle no we didn't get shot
yesterday so yesterday's better because
we can our memories are [ __ ] up our
memories trick us
our memories can't trick us right
everything i've always said that what
retrospect candy coats everything oh you
you said that that's me thinking that's
i mean i've never heard you say that
yeah it was me
i said but i've never heard it well i
don't say it to you i say it to
sometimes different people why don't you
say it to me it's cool is it cool did
you make it up here i made it up yeah
well that was me not john lennon oh well
i didn't i didn't suspect john lennon
but no i didn't cause he brought him up
but retrospect candy coats everything
and that's something i made up and if i
was a rapper i would wrap it in my songs
and people be like oh that's interesting
well it's true i mean i'm not i'm just a
comedian people look back on the past
and remember that's why when we like
break up with someone and then a couple
years later we're like god i shouldn't
have done it that was the best
relationship in my life right no it
wasn't right you were unhappy
[ __ ] you're only remembering the
good parts our brains are not perfect
they're imperfect and when we look back
we remember times as better than they
really were and when we look forward we
think of we get like uh
doom doom cycles like we think about all
the bad [ __ ] that could happen because
it's unsettled it's like entropy second
law of thermodynamics you gotta [ __ ]
think of it
in a smart way but what what confuses me
is that he knows all this
he's not confused about why it's because
it's still scary
it's does the future is unknown you're
scared of what we don't know that's why
a lot of people don't that's why a lot
of whites don't like black people
because they're not around them well
sure but that's a little bit different
it's about experience versus like
dude i
i think that yeah that here's the deal
everyone is scared of the future period
that's fine feel that it's okay to be
scared dude it's normal it's okay to be
scared you would be weird if you weren't
scared you know what you'd be a [ __ ]
mouse or a frog right just you're a
human it's okay to be scared make your
body take the steps forward one at a
time dude and you're wearing that hat
that says life rips
life rips
life ripped isn't the slogan
he thinks it's life ripped life rips
it continues to rip you know what rips
now you know what rips now you know what
rips now now keeps coming [ __ ]
right that hat was cool but when you put
that [ __ ] skullenbones [ __ ] hand
on it it upgraded you didn't used to
have that you don't think of the things
that you could be doing and you could be
doing some bomb air [ __ ] and guess what
you're going to have in your life pain
and that's going to suck too but your
memory is going to candy-coat it and
you're always going to go back to
imagine if we all lived hundreds of
thousands of years we'd be like man
remember what it was like in [ __ ] 14
you know 60. that was so fun we didn't
have technology to ruin our lives and
you'd be like forgetting about all your
friends that were beheaded yep you've
seen the tudors or got like some virus
and died exactly dude those [ __ ] four
waves of the [ __ ] uh the sweating
disease or whatever the [ __ ] they had in
the tudors wow
and not something but yeah no they had
the sweating four ways of the sweating
four waves of the sweating disease oh
okay it happened during the i saw the
two you know when i watched the tudors
right yeah which is basically just
instructive and educational tutors well
i googled it afterwards and i said
okay but but we'd be like oh man
remember the time it was so great we
didn't have to worry about nuclear
weapons you had to worry about famine
you had to worry about candles setting a
whole town on fire you had to worry on
[ __ ] you had to worry about losing
seven children before you had a [ __ ]
son because your wife couldn't give
birth because all you were eating were
[ __ ] taters
you know what i mean yeah i mean the
life expectancy was like 12. you know
and the reason is because it was so hard
to get past birth exactly yeah so my
point is
make your body
do the physical things
about moving forward and then you can
make your mind do it but like you know
take the steps try different things
dude i feel you
retrospect candy coats
everything but here's the thing that's
not real bro the way to shift it around
is this the past you're being tricked by
your own brain the past sucked
the future at the very least might not
suck
it's possible that the future won't suck
the past i promise you [ __ ] did
okay because it was life and most life
is [ __ ] hard and shitty the future
could be good
okay that's it
yeah think about all the times you cried
in your life bro
maybe you won't cry tomorrow yeah and
that's in the future you'll never cry
again [ __ ] yeah
live
let's do it
oh my gosh it's chris or it's christian
matalia i love him this guy has crazy
happenstance that i'm submitting to a
video for this
one i wanted to ask you guys oh man when
it comes to talking to new people and
in social situations
how do you know when next to speak to
them and
in what order you talk
when
conversing
appropriately between two
news new people
hope that you guys are doing well and
best believe that i'm listening to every
episode of
lifeline
dude okay this is uh what is his name
stony raymond right
steve raymond stoney raymond i don't
know tick tock everyone's got a [ __ ]
silly name this guy
how does he do this i don't know okay
he's a good actor he's like yeah but
like he must have a little bit of this
in him yeah the cnc on this [ __ ]
dude how does he act so insecure so
yeah over the top but also real yeah
it's unbelievable yeah it's the funniest
kind of [ __ ] like it's the jim carrey
[ __ ] like he's going so overboard but
it's that funny yeah he's taking chances
you know him i mean no we've only
conversed online but i'm a huge fan of
his he's on tick-tock he's got like
millions of followers oh he does yeah
yeah yeah steve raymond he's hilarious
oh stovy raymond is the thing on his
thing that's why i the thing on this
thing okay anyway stover i mean so
anyway dude this guy is talking about
how do you know when to talk next first
of all if this guy was really like this
guy this guy would have a lot of [ __ ]
um
you got real a lot of problems oh yeah
you gotta you gotta breathe first of all
breathe really more i feel like when him
every time he makes a video he needs to
he's almost gonna [ __ ] pass out
you know what i mean like when you're
doing adr and you're just like you gotta
do a quick breathing thing you realize
how [ __ ] hard it is in 30 seconds you
start seeing spots yeah yeah yeah uh you
oh you know what dude have you seen love
on the spectrum
no
these guys are amazing man like they uh
they gotta they gotta like learn how to
go on date and they gotta learn how to
talk to people and they'll just be like
yo you look very nice today i think i'm
falling in love oh they're autistic
they're artistic yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then there and then the woman
the girl is like oh that's really nice
do you have a dog and it's like they
don't know what to say to each other but
it's very sweet and very uh nice
and very uh pure right and they're
saying what they want and what they
think is right and like
um i mean i think that's quite
charming and good because a lot of
people think too much about it and come
off as cool yeah collected like they
don't want to see literally whatever
[ __ ] that 100 people are just like you
know
dude what do i say i'm gonna do this
yeah i'm gonna wait six days just like
right yeah be the way you want to be
don't be [ __ ] cool yeah
being cool sucks anyway and here's the
other thing too there's [ __ ] seven
how many billions of people are in the
world
how many eight billion dollars right
eight billion yeah yeah i know oh okay
and that there is somebody for everybody
there's probably at least five people
for everybody i mean at least dude so
get out there and be cincy and find a
scentsy person find an insecure person
find somebody that matches your rhythm
of talking right that guy's hilarious
yeah although i don't know about anybody
could ever match that but no they maybe
definitely be entertained by it that's
for damn sure yeah i'll tell you what if
i was a chick i'd give you a shot
yeah i mean that's so fun dude plus i
need i need a nice man you know okay i
do i don't need a [ __ ] guy that's all
you know how much work it is to be cool
bro
well that's why it sucks it's it's
not real i know
it's it's you have to if you have to
work on it
it's not authentic right right right you
know i wish more guys were like that
honestly and i know that that guy is a
good actor and [ __ ] um i wonder how much
he's like that i i don't know cause to
be able to know how that works you got
to either be like that or really
observant
and uh it's one or the other he's also
been very cool to me online uh uh all
throughout my [ __ ] i like that guy a lot
all right well we like that guy follow
him on uh tick tock he's [ __ ] funny
dude you've sent me a lot of his [ __ ] i
think it's still v stovey raymond i
think can you keep raymond making dovey
or something you keep adding an ie or a
white stove raymond okay okay it's stove
raymond all right i like when shit's
cute i guess
hey
all right next
hey chris and matt my name is stephanie
i'm a huge fan of your show
chris i've been listening to your
podcast for forever now but i need some
advice
so i work in an industry where i'm
surrounded by people all the time
customers people that work there just
people in general i'm getting really
sick of the comments that they make on
the way that i look and how young i look
oh god 22 almost 23. i'm 411
i'm very much aware of the way that i
look yeah i just really hate when people
get out of their way and make comments
like are you old enough to work are you
still in high school and where are your
parents
so it's getting really old that people
take time out of their day and say
stupid comments like that to me
i know i should be thankful that i look
as young as i am but it's starting to
get old and i never know a comment to
say back to them
i hope you can help
dude how are you so eloquent the way she
was speaking
don't act like she's so young she
shouldn't be able to do that that's not
what i'm saying like dory no stuttering
and it was like she was like she's very
common collected it's why she's got a
job she's very good at talking to people
so now you're saying she's too young to
have that job no i mean that is so
so annoying dude when people
it's like they think
they're the first person that ever saw
you and they it's like they don't think
it through like um she's probably heard
there's a gazillion [ __ ] times filter
use filters you're not that clever
[ __ ] stop talking to this
person like she's nobody's ever seen her
before
people have seen her and they've made
the exact comment that you are gonna
make that you think is [ __ ] funny and
is not okay that's addressing everybody
else as far as i just said they should
call into lifeline yes yeah they should
but as far as
what you can do
i mean that it's hard coming up with
like a blanket response to the for this
kind of [ __ ] because sometimes you know
the tenor of the way people say things
are sometimes
more acceptable than others
no uh
so it's hard to be like
you know the worst is when someone's
like thinking they're really [ __ ]
funny and clever that is the worst i'm
sure some people are like
maybe actually being genuine and not
thinking about being funny but still
it's annoying hey like so concerned hey
right hold on right where are your
parents right yeah exactly that's
probably very actually uncommon but uh
yeah i don't know what do you want to go
look for your parents what do i want to
tell her yeah
oh well if they're commenting on how you
look you comment on how they look that's
how it is tit for tat dude you're at a
job that this happens okay all that
warfare i know why she would be hesitant
to do that though because they could
report her to this yeah but she can do
it first
and are you kidding she's a young woman
she could get i mean she could get
[ __ ] fired left and right
people that work their customers she's
talking about
dude
customers like her and say [ __ ] that it
really bothers her about her appearance
oh god that's actually really shitty
even phrasing it like that yeah that
sucks dude
i mean it's you know
it's fine it's it's really not
you're taking a little bit too far no
dude like 20 30 times a day someone
would be like you're so small
imagine that i mean nobody's saying
you're so small that's how she's
obviously hearing it she said she's 411.
it was a hundred pounds she literally is
so small okay see this is the problem i
didn't know that until now and that's
not the first thing i'm saying i said it
though okay said it so you weren't
listening i was thinking of the tutors
at that point okay that's [ __ ] i
think i i think that um
you say
you you know
oh well you look like a bird okay so now
what
and she's and they say i'm sorry what
and they say that's offensive and i say
you're talking about how i look young
and where are my parents and you talk
about how i should still be in high
school you look like a bird
now let's move on and do this work right
right i think tit for tat yeah right i
think she could
maybe say something like
like oh how cute you think you're the
first person that came up with that
that's good that's so cool oh you think
you're like the first person that ever
thought of that thing like great now can
we move on yeah like maybe condescending
be patronizing they've done it to you
feel free to do it back yeah don't do it
in a way that sounds angry but be angry
and let them know yeah how about this
plausible deniability how about this say
where are your parents this is what you
can do too go ahead say i'll be i'll be
here go say where are your parents oh
you look so young where are your parents
dead that'll be 1995. that's a good one
too that's that's an amazing really good
one that'll be amazing yeah yeah yeah
they go like this oh sorry they turned
into stevie raymond
and they give you more money they give
you double the amount that you requested
that's a good one yeah yep yeah cool so
yeah think of the version you have for
all of them think of the version that
you can turn it around and make them
feel really bad look the whole thing
about spin move mentality is dude have
fun with it man have fun with it good
qvc but have fun the whole thing with
spin move mentality is have fun with it
right not only do you need to you don't
necessarily need to do a spin move right
but you can also
simply feel
the mentality we have hoodies
we have
shirts
that's the back do we have hello can we
go for this
chuck's saying it's too low but i'm
going
i'm going lower
chuck you know what
one how many do we have left we don't
have that many left so you be lucky
god you've been doing that for so
[ __ ] long four
you might
think you'd have them for 100 you are
not
that's my favorite part yeah
you are not
getting them
for 80 you are not
the pause
getting them for forty dollars you are
can we go you are not
so loud getting them for ten dollars
right now for a limited time only
four
simple
payments
of 12 cents
[Laughter]
dude
spin move mentality
all right all right next one hey
[Music]
football fans
yeah so
football's huge right and the first
sunday of the nfl season is here and
draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl that's official so
you know it's real
is giving new customers a can't miss
offer to celebrate their return of the
nfl season yes dude right now new
customers can bet just five dollars and
get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly instantly if you're like me i
could be like well if you get five
dollars then what do you get double back
maybe you get like 10 but you get 200.
100
so
this is a no-brainer
uh
and as an added bonus there's more yeah
believe it there's more as an added
bonus for week one everyone can
experience the thrill of draftking's
early win promotion so so look it's
simple look bet on an nfl team to win if
your
team leads by 10 at any point during the
game any point then you get paid
instantly boom ka-ching even if your
team loses what download the draftkings
sportsbook app now and use promo code
lifeline to get 200
in free bets instantly 200
that's like a pass and go in monopoly
and when you place a five dollar bet
that happens this sunday okay so that's
code lifeline only at draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details
hey chris hey matt huge fan of the
podcast um chris you're looking really
fresh today
love the fit love the hair super funky
love it she said chris matt yeah you
have really nice hands
i don't know if anyone's ever told you
that but i just really felt like you
needed to hear it that's a kink but i
have no chance too
i need some advice because i'm
moving out for the first time moving out
of my parents house i'm going across the
country to a writing program
in a film school
really excited but i've never moved out
before so um
i'm going to be going to vancouver
british columbia i'm wondering if you
guys have any tips for like moving out
to the city
art to a bigger city moving to the west
coast um
kind of like networking getting into the
entertainment industry
anything that you could possibly offer
me oh yeah i will take um any stories
from like when you guys were moving out
in your early twenties
yeah um huge fan
bro i just love that she's
[ __ ] moving up dude this is exactly
where that first guy needs to be dude
living in the future but not so much but
she's a you know honestly women live in
the future way more than men you know
that they're better at planning they're
better women are like long-term thinking
what is it going to be like when dude
kristen is just like i can't wait till
we die together you know what i mean
it's just like dude
let's have lunch yeah yeah you know
it's so crazy dude
literally chris chris would literally be
like when we're old and our kids are out
of the house and just how amazing is
going to be when they come over for our
last thanksgiving right just like what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah
but dude she's um
yeah first of all vancouver i love
vancouver besides the rain but i was
going to say that so don't jump on me
right but besides the rain dude oh my
god i don't know where you're from if
you're from a cold area that's fine it's
gonna be cold to ship but let me tell
you it rains a lot besides the rain but
dude christmas in [ __ ] vancouver
is absolutely
awesome dude the lights the beautiful
coldness all of it i flew an event i've
been a venture a few times and one time
i flew into vancouver and got in a cab
go where i was going i rolled down the
window and the air was hitting me in the
face and i was like
this sounds like horseshit and i swear
to god it's not i was like intoxicated
by how [ __ ] fresh
and crisp the air was i like felt high
wow dude i felt high from the [ __ ]
air in vancouver so what a [ __ ] did
did this [ __ ] so many doobies before
that and didn't realize i didn't even i
mean you're right dude
just just on the car
are you serious right now hey
uber guy
i've been known to do [ __ ] some
doobies on the doobie brother out of the
tour but i did not i did not it's just
the air in vancouver but we should talk
to her are we hot boxing in this weird
colored cab because it's a weird color
because we're not in america and they
don't have yellow ones what
wow
um okay so
advice though but she needs advice now
opinion about the city she's going to be
fine but also the way
yeah um
you're gonna be fine
trust in you you know what dude trust in
yourself but i would say but not to be
too overly cautious i know but trust in
yourself but don't be too trusting of
other people because everyone else is
trying to get ahead too you're out in
the big city you're a very kind person
it's very obvious and obviously you're a
go-getter that's clear but don't
blindly trust
other people who seem to have your
interests at their heart very good trust
me they have their interests very good
and let me tell you another thing too
about vancouver especially um don't take
a wrong turn yeah yeah dude
the [ __ ] opiate addiction and the
[ __ ] heroin forget it i say here on
like that because like i'm like a rapper
what are you what word are you even
heroin heroin okay i don't do that dude
even though that's the word
not when that's not how naz says it
heron
i mean heron is a guy heron in your
veins oh okay you know still a bird so
um what it's a bird heron
harry yeah but that's all you're saying
right no it's not yeah does nice rap
about birds
no herron and a blue jay so um
yeah so you take a right turn dude and
seriously it is the it is the [ __ ]
you gotta be careful you step on a
syringe so basically always wear shoes
watch where you're going and don't trust
in too many people too much but trust in
yourself and
bro i can't wait till let me tell you
something i know you're probably gonna
want to get home to your family for
christmas but right now if she's not
christian
well yeah she could be jewish you're
saying she could be a lot of things
i'm just saying she might not be
christian who does it you can be
whatever religion you want she can yeah
it's up to her but i'm saying most
people
okay she's probably but it's beautiful
that time of year is your point yeah so
right now holiday a lot of people go
home for the holidays yeah dude like
you're trying to like catch nah dude i'm
just saying
it's not about christmas it's about the
time of year that's all you're getting
pissed no i'm not getting pissed i'm
just saying
she wants to ride out december there
it's gonna be cold but it's so nice too
yeah yeah it is so nice yeah and
vancouver has starbucks across from
starbucks yes and i go in both and tim
hortons tim horton's too yes uh i wonder
where she's from but the thing
that you said about don't make a wrong
turn that's true but vancouver is very
safe because they are safe places to do
those drugs they're not like drilling
and dealing on the streets addicts go to
a safe zone and get a clean needle right
so it's like not as [ __ ] up as say
skid row in downtown ola that's why
there's so many starbucks because they
have them in starbucks
uh yeah let me get a tall maca a tall
mocha uh
thing there and then
herron
i'm sorry i said because i'm like and
then call it out they're like nas
all right
okay you're gonna do great
congratulations on moving out going to
the big city stud what's up guys my name
is daniel
my dad's 63 and he's an accountant uh he
says every penny he earns which is fine
i've learned a lot from him cool but
anytime my brothers or eyes spend money
on something that he thinks is
unimportant oh god uh i wouldn't say
he's disappointed but
he kind of disapproves
um so i guess a question would be how do
you guys handle
trying to teach your parents things
uh even though they seem like they're
kind of already set in their ways [ __ ]
yeah dude
uh yeah let me know it's tough it's so
tough dude it's so tough i mean we deal
with that i don't think you can
teach them anything i think the only
thing you can
sort of
get them to understand
is is that
you are your own person and the way you
do things has validity to you so
therefore it has validity in general so
they shouldn't be so
uh
looking down their nose at you like that
you're a [ __ ] adult and you're
clearly a rational one so if you want to
buy [ __ ] i don't know rims on your
car and your dad's like oh here we go
this he's treating like a child yeah
yeah and that's not right that's shitty
dude so you could i don't know what kind
of guy your dad is but you could at the
very least just be like look dad like
just because you don't want to do it
doesn't mean that it's
absolutely a [ __ ] thing to do
i want to do it i make my money the way
i make it it's my money i can do what i
want and it's a thing to do in the world
relax
[ __ ] get the stick out of your ass
and you want me to be happy don't you
like isn't that your goal for your child
like that's the thing about it is like
what makes you happy like sometimes i
spend money and i'm like i shouldn't
have done that and i'm like but it makes
me happy though and it makes me happy
and because i'm happy that's good and
you're gonna die what are you gonna do
with that money when you're [ __ ] dead
i mean not everybody in the world has
died but they're gonna i said you don't
know that no everyone who has been born
is going to die has everyone who's been
born died
not yet so then that doesn't work but
they're going to i didn't say they did
die you don't know that yes i do
give me a version of the future that
somebody alive now is not going to die
anthony hopkins
what about him he hasn't died yet
he hasn't died yet the guy who played
he's gonna die the guy who plays the
first who's that guy not give me an
example of a person who isn't going to
die
give me an example of someone
how someone alive now could possibly not
die a few days ago i would have said
michelle to gorbachev but he died so
there's there's one in your favor
there's one in your favor you think is
not gonna die how could a living person
not die
i'm just saying
you don't know with like uh what what's
the tren what's the [ __ ] movie that
johnny depp did the transcendence what's
that [ __ ] one transcendent trend what
is that one transcendence yeah trying to
send us google it instead of just
thinking it's just like just [ __ ] you
got a computer transcendence
transcendence you don't know about that
you don't know about uh synchronicity
and what the [ __ ] gonna happen but he
did die his his consciousness
lived on but he his body died gotcha
technicality also that's fake that's a
movie
[Laughter]
using like meet joe black
michelle black
brad pitt's character didn't die
i mean look he pulled up bicentennial
man so different so different so
different he brought up bicentennial
movie he wanted to look up yeah
oh movies oh i like this other movie
yeah dude
thank you there you go like i stinking
ass said
look at that look
how dumb his face is there i hate
movies that the poster is just one big
picture of the actor's face you know
what i don't like too when movies give a
character a name and then center that
name in a tagline like what
yesterday dr will caster was only human
who the [ __ ] is dr wilcaster dude cause
that's johnny depp [ __ ] like we
already care about him yeah like what
the [ __ ] so
that's [ __ ] hilarious like don't send
her the name that means nothing to you
yeah that poster sucks that poster is
way better yeah but some fan made that i
guarantee you think yeah dude or it's a
foreign thing please show it on the
video on youtube cause polish polish
[ __ ] german [ __ ] latin american [ __ ] all
those posters are always better american
posters are just like
some photoshopped face of matt damon and
unrelated to the movie and then another
photoshop face of jeff bridges on amazon
and it's just like this is true grit
this is true great
look at that the the blu-ray cupboard's
so inactive dude
dude that blu-ray cover sucks just faces
look at the chick with their hair like
look at like at least get a still
picture of her well that sucks of course
morgan freeman's in that movie you know
yeah is that morgan freeman it's just
all like someday we will all travel wow
dude so true
all right next one dude oh wow okay oh
that that but well how about this i will
i will go to say
find a blu-ray cover that's actually
good yeah i bet you
number three isn't just based on the
poster of the movie number one bad
[ __ ] thing uh
art blu-ray post because blue raiders
were only around for like three years
you know yeah dude so true but wait
just to wrap up that [ __ ] guy before
you start the next video
oh yeah you're your own person you may
not be able to teach your parents
anything but you can at least get it
into his head that
he was once your age and he can remember
that it's not that [ __ ] long ago so
just get it through his head that you
are your own person you have the things
that you like that are willing that you
think are worth your [ __ ] money that
you made not his [ __ ] him and it makes
me happy dude it makes me happy yeah
right yeah
if you ask your dad what's the number
one thing you want happiness for my son
i don't give a [ __ ] dude if calvin isn't
happy i'm not happy i want him happy i
don't care if he wants to grow up and be
a [ __ ] train conductor i don't even
know if that's a good job but i'm just
saying i would never see him because
he'd be on the road a lot but whatever
calvin was drink conducted perfectly
honestly yeah that is true they have
cool outfits yeah hats but my point is
whatever then bad example you know
working at kinko's and no shame if you
work at kinko's you're trying to get by
whatever but like no one would wish that
on their son i guess right because
kinko's will probably be out of business
soon it already is it's fedex there you
go so right so if you work at kinko's
pretty much you're done you're living in
the past like that guy right the first
guy yeah first okay so um
yeah dude just happiness man it's what
makes you happy in this man yeah uh
great okay great uh great
next one bing bong bing bong what up
y'all this is luca magnata uh the homie
that was asking about
asking a girl out at work oh yeah um i
ended up getting to meet her just in
passing
um and honestly wasn't really my vibe um
you know part of the reason i had said
that i was potentially interested in
asking her out
is because i just was going based on
jeff's looks right and everything
you got to get to know them a little bit
um it just wasn't my thing so i didn't
ask her out
um but here's a separate question my
brother and i do a podcast about movies
we talk about movie news and like we
review movies and stuff like that it's
really fun for us we look up to you guys
we you know we're inspired by your
guys's podcast
um what are some ways that we can make
our podcast more um entertaining or
successful or
interesting what are some ways that you
guys have found helps you when you're
having a conversation like being
entertaining and also being yourself
i don't know just some advice on having
a podcast that you started with your
brother where you talk about movies so
thanks guys peace
do it naked well no people yeah no
people are you have to remember that
people are subscribing to not
necessarily the actual
uh
idea or the content it's you yeah 100 so
let your you come through as best as
possible and it's a lot harder for some
people you know i think for comedians
it's generally easier because they're
already figured out who they are as a
performance
uh uh uh
performance wise and um you know for
people who are not comedians or
performers i think it's a lot harder so
it may take you a little bit longer to
catch your groove i don't know how long
you've been doing this podcast but um
yeah i think that uh people are
subscribing to you ultimately uh so
that's what you gotta uh focus on having
that come through oh i was gonna say
something similar which is like you
um
if it's your brother especially you guys
have a rapport that
you know brothers and
sisters siblings brother and sister
whatever they
they have a rapport that is common among
siblings but their specific rapporters
are not
they they are not similar they're very
unique every every pair of brothers pair
of sisters brother and sister has a
unique bond
and
whatever that is try to tap into that
it's almost like try to
do it as if the cameras or microphones
are not there
because people will want to tune in to
the see a unique bond people like
whatever you want to call it realness
authenticity they want to see or listen
to
people being themselves and when you
have a unique bond with someone in
particular they want to see that even
more so again i think just sort of
echoing what chris said don't
talk about the movies yeah but that's
the buck and background noise it's
actually about you two and how you guys
vibe with each other so uh assuming you
guys do have a unique bond which i'm
sure you do make that front and center
and lead with that every step of the way
every time there's a question about what
direction to take the show lead with the
unique bond that you guys have
not the kind of movies that you're gonna
talk about not whatever whatever
whatever it's always gonna should always
start with the bond that you guys have
also how about that's great that you
realize that girl's not for you see this
is the thing about you know not
realizing you this is the thing about
living in your head you know what in
addiction we call it magical thinking
it's like you think that you you see
someone and you create this scenario
that doesn't necessarily exist that you
want to
you play out like this movie you know
like oh i saw her she was in the corner
you know
we're supposed to meet or whatever the
[ __ ] it is and then you meet somebody
i'm glad you let reality sink in yeah
that maybe this isn't right because a
lot of people especially like you know
addicts or me or whatever
they might be like
oh this means something i need to you
know i need to talk to her because of
this or whatever it is nothing means
anything there are no signs stop it with
that [ __ ] nothing is meant to be
things happen and when they're in front
of you and they seem good or are good
you follow that path what
senileist no no i don't i don't mean
that from like the whole world
no matter what i just mean that things
out in the world
there's no deeper meaning to them you
make of the world what it gives you what
it offers you and you take it or don't
okay so it's a nihilist then it's like
okay okay absolutely not um but yeah i
mean i think that's
that's like uh there's that joke in
jerry seinfeld's book that you know when
we were kids sign language yeah i
remember he talks about how he doesn't
have the problem with dating anymore
because he just stopped approaching
people because he can see it someone a
beautiful woman and then he can see play
out their whole trajectory right or like
they're getting starting to get into
fights
oh gotcha butt heads and like they hate
each other by the time they're dying
it's like you know if you don't live
right then in that moment you can see
ahead a little bit for see maybe what it
would be like to be on your tenth date
and it might be awesome and it might be
what's happening are you playing a trick
on yourself oh boy it's a nihilist
so yeah
no no i'm not okay we're gonna talk
about that after the show okay cool wow
gonna let me out
hey chris matt thank you guys so much
for all you're doing here i'm a huge fan
so my wife and i have been trying to get
pregnant for about two years now and
we've had no luck we haven't gone to the
doctor or anything like that because we
just don't want to know that if you know
what i mean yeah still young as crap i'm
26 but my wife is 30 and she feels like
we should start talking about other
options young is crap um the big one is
adoption and i would love that kid with
all my heart don't get me wrong i i want
a kid so bad there's nothing that i want
more than to be a father
um but i just feel like having one of my
own might be a little different uh
i i feel like a dick saying that but
any advice you guys have at all would be
great a lot of people feel that way yeah
i understand i feel like a dick um yeah
you want to go ahead or i mean i you
know i i actually think about this
sometimes because i i you know
obviously calvin is mine no dna test
needed you get a [ __ ] you know
nervous like i mean you see the [ __ ]
face he looks like me and my dad but
like so there's no way it's not mine but
um
so but my point is
i i do think about that sometimes like
what if i adopted a child and it just it
didn't look like me or
and and and i wonder how much of that is
ego based and how much of that is
uh just evolution based to where you
feel like you created this life
with you and your balls and how
right there's more to it but it starts
with your balls
and uh
started with a pair of balls
that's how the bible begins
um
here comes adam and so
so yeah so i wonder how much it would
you know you've tried for two years
that's a [ __ ] sure and also though it
is hard to get pregnant sometimes dude
sometimes like
you just like aren't busting at the
right times and you can't seem to get to
bust at the right time like four days
ago sometimes women have shorter windows
it doesn't mean anything's wrong yeah
but but uh semen or sperm lasts for two
days right but maybe he busts and his
[ __ ] goes away he does the job quick and
he doesn't have the it's not in there
for the same time period if he busts
yeah then it this the the splurt lasts
for two days and if you're in the window
and the sports chilling
and the window opens the splurk goes up
hey look the window's open and they run
in two years is a long time so maybe
something's going on and he said you
don't want to go to doctor why he said
for he doesn't want to find out what
could be bad or whatever but i would say
you're fine you're 26 you don't need to
go to doctor right away i would say it's
only 24 tries though that's not that
many dude i guess so keeps a lot but
it's not crazy just keep sparting
get her to [ __ ] uh
roll around with the knees up or
whatever the [ __ ] i mean i don't know
worst doctor ever have you got her to
roll around with her knees up but take
two of these call me in the morning
but the truth is
you gotta if if it's if you're starting
to think that way about other you don't
go you don't start thinking about
adoption as an alternative without
exploring yourself and her self to the
end you got to go to a [ __ ] doctor
buddy yeah you have to go to the doctor
doesn't mean something's wrong it could
be something super simple you could have
a low sperm account and he could give
you some cbd you know what i mean 10
code if you go to the link and it's
congrats you hit type in congrats but
but you could you know it could be
something like that it could be like oh
i see the problem yeah right easy fix
take this pill once a week and yeah
like you don't even know you're thinking
about oh my god you're you're infertile
or all this scary [ __ ] dude that if
that's true you could think about
adoption but there's no reason to be
thinking about that now i don't suppose
don't suppose anything dude you're not a
doctor and a doctor is a doctor but do
go to the doctor you definitely go to
the doctor you don't want to live with
this like maybe i'm this maybe i'm that
maybe nothing's wrong maybe this is
wrong you don't want to live in that
constant state of doubt just go get some
[ __ ] answers i'm sure it's not even
that bad in the first place and then
once you get the answers you go home and
do some busta busts and lead to a little
wham
wow
and uh pablo francisco and honestly the
the
um the last resort can be adoption and
that's fine and that's a beautiful thing
or a.i so well you never know how the
future what it holds right again
you're gonna pull up with johnny depp
poster again transcendence is real
synchronicity is real but yeah just
don't [ __ ] think the doctor means the
worst possible thing it doesn't does not
yeah does not people don't like to go to
doctors i get it he was probably pricked
with a thing wrong they couldn't find
his vein or something when he was
younger now he has trauma but okay such
a bad therapist you know
why are you coughing so much dude what's
going on
talk about doctors oh god damn dude all
right all right next next
hey matt and chris i'm hannah and i'm
from georgia
and i need some advice my mom is an
alcoholic we don't get along
or have a relationship really and she
has the rest of the liver
she's not doing great um my siblings
really want me to build a relationship
with her
because she's not doing great we don't
know how much longer she's going to be
here and i'm really against it because
i don't want to give her the power to
hurt me again i already was hurt when i
didn't have a mom
to help me pick out a prom dress or sign
a lease on a car yeah you know so
i don't want to give her that power to
hurt me again if she's only gonna
disappear again yeah
i don't know what to do
do i just suck it up and be at the
hospital with them because that's what
my siblings want or
do i say screw you i'm fine without you
and i don't want to get hurt again
help
uh yeah this is the kind of thing i
would love to be able to ask questions
about uh
making me want that [ __ ] private
session with her but for for for what
you're giving us the amount of
information that you've given us
i think first of all
that's [ __ ] painful and i'm really
sorry that that's your experience with
your mother that's
not fun uh i know some people who've had
similar experiences with one parent or
another and it's just it kind of colors
your whole life and it's sad and it's
[ __ ] really really difficult so
i'm sorry you got to go through that but
uh don't
i would advise you to not do
anything just because your siblings are
saying you should they have their own
relationship with their mother that
doesn't mean yours should mirror that
doesn't mean that yours you have your
own unique experience with your mother
that doesn't they shouldn't be able to
tell you exactly how yours should be or
how you should operate in your
relationship with her you have been hurt
by her in number of ways clearly and
you're not ready to open yourself up to
being hurt again and that totally makes
sense that being said if she's actually
close to dying
i would give it more consideration than
than i'm
that i'm initially inclined to advise
because i just don't i don't think that
it's worth
uh
the fear of her hurting you again i
don't know if that's worth spending the
rest of your life
knowing that you could have maybe tried
to open up some kind of one of
communication with your mother again but
she's gone too early that you that you
know i feel like the best
yeah
that's a very good point but i also
think that you know
it's not just about you ultimately it is
but here's the thing it's not just about
you
it's about your siblings too if you do
care about them and you love them you
need to consider them but ultimately you
are the most important to you so
the whole deal is you may not
know what's best for you at this moment
and to live in regret
with not giving your mother another
chance might be something that you might
experience for the rest of your life
between the two things
letting your siblings down and also you
might not know what's best for you right
now i would heavily consider
uh being there
for everyone
and being with your mom through her
final moments but only you know what's
best and you are most important so if
that supersedes all of it
then i understand you not being there i
definitely understand you're not being i
don't think you should feel bad about it
did i miss something did is her did she
say her mom's actively dying she says
she has cirrhosis and it's not going
well okay uh i i
i mean maybe i don't know how bad it is
yeah she's maybe she can't even really
have a conversation but it might be if
she's up and able to talk and
communicate and totally lucid it might
be worth
having
this specific conversation with your mom
just tell her like
you know i want to be able to be here
for you and i want to have a better
relationship you know before you might
leave this earth but like
you know the truth of the matter is
you've really hurt me over the years you
know your disease has not only alienated
one of your children me but it's totally
ruining your body and leading to very
possibly your death
so like
you know
can we meet somewhere in the middle here
so we can both get what we want i know
i mean your mom doesn't want to have you
alienated either she's got this disease
that got in the way she's got her own
[ __ ] demons whatever i'm not making
excuses for her i'm just saying like she
doesn't want this either and if there's
a way for you to
figure out you know if you stay in your
lane and approach it in a way that
you're careful but also caring to your
mother and to yourself it's possible
that that could open up some kind of
relationship with her that is positive
before she goes and then you know not to
sound crass but like end her life
for you on a positive note would be i
think extremely valuable to you in your
situation um
yeah man we like to keep this uh podcast
sometimes
with some levity but i'll tell you that
was a serious one yeah so i like the
serious ones though yeah and i like the
serious ones too i mean we should talk
to you know the producer about maybe you
know maybe there's more funny ones
whatever
um i do feel i do feel uh i do feel for
you you know obviously addiction is
rough it's it's stronger than your mom
and it's stronger than your family and
it [ __ ] sucks but uh
you know
uh
let us know i guess
yeah follow up something changes let us
know for sure
yeah
and that fan was working hard up there
did you see that it looked like she was
gonna fly away jesus christ all right
she's got one of those spinny hats on
you yeah yeah all right next
oh hey guys oh he's cute it's mal and
bowie here
yeah we were just watching videos of cal
and he has to kiss his face every time
oh you're cute
um
yeah that's a boy and uh so my question
today is
i had this little man when i was
24. and everyone's favorite thing to say
to me is but you're a baby yourself oh
my god you should have waited and
you're only 20 in your 20s you should
have enjoyed it more i'm like this is
what i want to do
so uh just wondering what some of my
responses should be and
what i should say to them because it's
kind of getting old
but yeah thanks guys
really appreciate it
that baby is so wait a second wait a
second i gotta get this straight i know
what she said but i gotta say it out
loud so i'm [ __ ]
there are people in her life most people
are miserable that tell her
she should not have had her son because
she's only twenty-four
i don't know if they say specifically
that but yeah she was leading to what
people were saying that uh oh but what
about living your your youth you know uh
now you're a mom something like that you
know [ __ ]
those those people are miserable [ __ ]
off also do they have like like
dude i mean i i i love the way i did it
i have you know but
if i could have had kids earlier now
that i have calvin i'm like well that
would have been [ __ ] fantastic you
know i don't understand these people
that are like there are people that show
up and they're like hey man i've had a
great week dude i got away i was away
from the wife and the kid and like i'm
just like
what i never want to be away dude yeah i
bring them on tour i don't understand
these people's lives there's two
different types of people like this man
there's people that are just born to do
that [ __ ] which you are you had your
child you're living
dude it's also awesome to be young with
your child yeah you know like
we're both very young i'm only 42 and
like i get to be with calvin and i can
run around and [ __ ] and my knees don't
hurt i mean you know and i and we we
tackle each other we have a good time
and he learns the you know sounds like
you need another therapist
the do's and don'ts but i'm joking but
like you can
this is great this is the best time of
your life i just can't believe there are
people that say that first of all just
to be absolutely as clear as possible
not that you exhibited any doubt here
but those people are 100
in the wrong [ __ ] titanic [ __ ]
okay they're also projecting they they
are miserable
and i'm glad it doesn't seem to be you
know any skin off your back but like
what you can say to them is something
like
excuse me you're an [ __ ] or if you
don't want to be that direct
confrontational you can just say
why
in what world would i not want to have
this
sun
in my life right now like what what are
they even positing that like it would be
better if like you shoved them back
inside and this never happened like wow
what if that's what they meant he put
him back in there he's here and he's a
beautiful [ __ ] boy what are you
talking about yeah say that like what
are you what could you possibly see
she's so nice you could see she smiles
so much and she's like oh wow when she
eats it dude don't eat it anymore don't
just be like you see this baby yeah this
is great yeah
yeah
yeah what are you talking about this is
so fun i get to be young with this
[ __ ] yeah okay well you don't
need to say [ __ ] let's go in the
sandbox dude don't project your [ __ ]
on me don't project your
oh i didn't live my youth to the fullest
your sad life on me and do it with your
[ __ ] beautiful smile if you want you
can even say something like you know
write a note it sounds like with a smile
if you want it sounds like projection
like do i seem unhappy i'm not unhappy
at all i'm over the moon happy yeah i
love my son i love my life what about
you
what happened in your life that you feel
like you can just say that willy-nilly
to me you don't know anything about it
like i seem happy because i am happy
what about you turn that [ __ ] around i
don't know i don't like
mom said to me recently she was like you
know maybe get cal on a better schedule
or something like that and i was i said
nah we got it
it's like sometimes just that's enough
you know
like nah don't say that yeah but that's
different that's mom trying to be
helpful
that's not the same thing this person
whoever she's counting in her life
they're trying to actually they're
trying to be mean
how could you justify that i don't think
they're always trying to be mean i think
that they have their own [ __ ] going on
and they do think they're definitely not
trying to help i think that they're
asking because they want to figure it
out themselves sometimes because like
what did i do wrong it's definitely
about them dude it's not about you yeah
well i mean most of the time it's about
them
yeah but that's just so [ __ ] annoying
they're just like they're literally
thinking like hmm well i didn't get to
have enough blow jobs when i was in my
20s
what about your you know what i mean
interesting yeah i didn't get to go
do all those retreats that i wanted to
go because i
what about you and she and she's like my
life's different than yours yeah i mean
i i did the retreats i gave the [ __ ]
i wanted to that is
that is astounding people didn't know
you're not gay i'm saying her dude that
is astounding people hate
annoying
and shitty and absolutely [ __ ] those
people yeah i backed it up as much as i
wanted to already yeah okay you know
what i'm saying i gotcha i got you i got
you i did the horizontal as much as i
wanted to and i have retreat i done
retreat i have retreat also
also i have my child look at his smile
look at my smile we smile so much we're
basically the mask in the first purge
our faces hurt we smile yeah dude ouch
just go like this go like this when they
say that go like this ouch
when they say what what's wrong and be
like my face hurts because i smile so
much that's how happy i am ouch my face
and my baby's face is basically the
first bus from the first purge ow
yeah that's good perfect and then they
go like this
and they go like this do you see what
you're doing you're projecting spin move
out of there i knew that was coming
lifeline merch dot com get your spin
move mentality shits uh go to the link
[ __ ] pure spectrum get your legs to
stop moving okay chill and absolutely
[ __ ] get your anxiety at an all-time
low and be did i was at a wedding the
other day and i was looking around and i
was like why am i so awake dude i think
that's the answer i'm telling you right
now 10 off use code congrats hit that
link and you know what's up dude if you
have a question once you finish it take
them out all right yeah and if you need
some private advice get some more
details in there like that second last
one i would have loved more details to
advise a little bit more specific a
little bit more tailored to the person
in this situation go to mattdalia.com
private advice sessions with me and not
him so it'll be even [ __ ] better and
more focused on you
and if you have a question click the
link in the description below or go to
white's life
go to white's life and go to
watchlifeline.com
thanks guys hell yeah love you all
[Music]